that guy who came back
they called at the office
yes I get 1 bit of jitters from this
it concerns 1 employer
who thinks his employee is not sick enough
this kid gets called into the office
and gets 1 vaststellingsovereenkomst under his nose
that is 1 kind of statement in which parties tell
that they can no longer work together
it is in fact 1 kind of voluntary dismissal
but the employer in question
didn't have a paw to stand on here
1 employer does not determine whether you are sick enough
to go to work or not
or be outdoors
if 1 employer thinks you are not sick enough
then that 1 health and safety service can send to you
or 1 company doctor
but this is not possible
of course you can if you are sick
best with 1 vaststellingsovereenkomst
leave your employer
but this does not feel very voluntary how this went
leave you in this kind of situation
not intimidating your employer
your employer is simply not about it